é licenciada em astronomia e gosto de
olhar as estrelas integra o projeto
galileu mobile um programa internacional
de divulgação da astronomia s
no começo de agosto
ele vai ter o desinteresse pelo
conhecimento não lavam foi a todos
é eu chamo nuno gomes é cria com
sabedoria desculpa aquelas pessoas que
estavam à espera de encontrar um outro
nuno gomes
eu não sou extra o futebol mas vem cá
formados no trio de estrelas é vamos
falar da importância da astronomia e da
ciência na sociedade e vamos apresentar
um grupo de divulgação científica
chamado pelo global
eu acho que não é pretensão do governo
começamos então a astronomia é
porventura a mais antiga das ciências
naturais são inúmeras as evidências
arqueológicas cruz mostram que o homem
desde tempos imemoriais com o tempo o
céu astronomia tem demonstrado que o
universo é incrivelmente bonito e
fascinante coppio é um instrumento é que
não se introduza um mundo completamente
novo
descobrimos mais coisas do que a ganhar
uma vez imaginou podem imaginar
através do scoop uma experiência que
mais produz uma sensação de profunda
admiração e que nos deixem greves pronto
que estamos a observar planetas na via
láctea lojas em chamas globo lados
galáxias cometas
eclipse do sol
eclipse da lua mesmo que os observados
mais de uma vez mantém intacto poder nos
deixarem estas são um dia não só uma vez
constroem os amadores mas falar em como
eles provavelmente vão viu ou ouviu
dizer que adoram observar o céu ea
palavra amador significa exatamente isso
aqui é um casal por gosto ou por amor à
astronomia teria ocupado um lugar no
ensino fundamental uma vez que ela tá em
o governo inspirados parcialmente para o
mundo da ciência através das maravilhas
do cosmos nos despertar a motivação para
aprender mas acima de tudo porque nos
oferece a possibilidade por sabermos a
nossa pequenez para o universo
isso faz nós pessoas mais conscientes
para um lugar que ocupamos no mundo e
plantas nossas responsabilidades para
com o planeta
todos estes motivos e eu acredito que a
astronomia ea ciência podem contribuir
para que o mundo seja um lugar melhor
no entanto os projectos economicamente
complicados como o que atravessamos
agora três anos entre outras coisas por
assistirem a um corte acentuado na
educação e no investimento e no
financiamento à investigação científica
week público em investigação e
desenvolvimento nos países mais
desenvolvidos do mundo têm vindo a
diminuir nos últimos anos nunca
ultrapassando 1 por cento do produto
interno bruto
se juntarmos o investimento privado no
g20 eu sublinho que a união européia faz
parte do g 20 em média
em maio de 2003 deste ano era de 2,04
por cento
então coloque stalin e este valor
financia toda investigação e toda a
tecnologia que possam imaginar
desde a pesquisa médica as viagens
espaciais como exemplo eu vou apresentar
um usuário que já foi apresentado numa
tecla global junto em 2008 o boxe é um
físico inglês
não quero que vocês se assustem com esta
é este é um gráfico que é publicado
todos os anos o jornal the guardian
inglaterra e que mostra de que forma é
que o dinheiro público é publicado no
país
os valores que lá estão não quero que a
cimentação estão porcentagem do produto
interno bruto e vamos pedir sim para
prestarem atenção essa vozinha por
maioria que está aqui perto do canto
inferior direito amplo à aula e no reino
unido no ano de 2011 2012 o investimento
público só falar de um instrumento
fundamental unicamente neste caso em
investigação e desenvolvimento respondeu
aquela bolinha pequenina vermelha que
estava vendo isso foi inferior a 0,6 por
cento do orçamento e do produto interno
bruto mas astronomia parte da exploração
espacial e outras áreas de ciência e da
engenharia tem a vantagem de trazer
torno econômico uma vez que ela
impulsiona é a tecnologia de ponta por
exemplo o programa apollo que o homem à
lua no ano no final da década de 60 e
princípio da década de 70
além do trabalho na área que foi foi
correspondeu a um investimento enorme
trouxe um retorno é 14 superior para a
economia dos estados unidos da américa e
som da tve econometrics 1975
o programa apollo a si próprio
além de que trouxe importantes nas
gerações vindouras em termos de
inspiração e motivação para o
conhecimento para o investimento e para
a investigação isso é algo que é muito
difícil se não mesmo impossível de medir
o enviado mesmo descobertas científicas
é na área do conhecimento puro tem
repercussões na sociedade com muitas
vezes só são mais sentidas muito mais
tarde
é o caso da descoberta da penicilina que
permitiu a cura de muitas doenças e por
exemplo o desenvolvimento da mecânica
quântica no final 7
em princípio do século 20 um dos
produtos dessa desde o desenvolvimento
também que a única coisa que foi algumas
décadas mais tarde é invenção do
transistor e não sei se vocês todos têm
noção de que sem o transe história sus e
tecnológica e economia atuais eram de
todo impossível
alguns países da áfrica do sul estão a
apostar na ciência e na tecnologia como
motor do desenvolvimento sustentável da
economia e nesse sentido tem
desenvolvido programas de divulgação
científica com o intuito de sensibilizar
as populações para a importância dessa
ciência mesma obrigação e na mesma linha
de pensamento em meados de 2008 um grupo
de estudantes de doutoramento em
astronomia resolveram organizar uma
viagem à américa do sul no ano seguinte
em 2009 no âmbito do proae internacional
é da astronomia com o intuito de inovar
é esta ciência às escolas do chill da
bolívia e agora mostra o curso que nós
fizemos nossa primeira exposição levou
dois metros a ser percorrido
respondam por cerca de 7 mil quilômetros
e foi feito de carro e desta forma
surgiu global
o galã global é por isso um problema
entre integrantes de divulgação
científica totalmente voluntário e
portanto também sem fins lucrativos e
convida os professores os estudantes e
as pessoas em geral olhar em vantagem os
olhos e contemplarem no céu e discutirem
idéias sobre o cosmos mandamos uma
mensagem de união debaixo do mesmo céu e
forçando a saída que apesar das
fronteiras serem criações humanas
artificiais
o céu é algo que pertence a todos e que
nunca poderá ser dividido os nossos
objetivos passam por envolver os alunos
em atividades científicas
e por realizar acções de formação com os
professores ferramentas úteis para
inspirar seus alunos e despertar da
paixão pela ciência estimulados o
pensamento crítico e isso para nós é
fundamental estimular o pensamento
crítico das crianças e das pessoas com
quem trabalhamos mobilizamos para
partilharmos as nossas culturas
diferentes visões do cosmos e
conhecimentos em gastronomia
todos sob o mesmo céu sem fronteiras
para além do inspirado astronomia tem
este poder de permitir a livre troca de
idéias e de aproximar as diferentes
culturas por exemplo fly eu peço a vossa
atenção para o canto superior direito
tenha uma apresentação de uma
constituição em guiné e inscreva na
américa do sul é elas representaram
viram aquelas estrelas uma arma de
arremesso que chama onda e nós temos uma
constelação de frente exatamente com
aquelas mesmas estrelas
quem sabe com a situação é essa nossa
gastronomia
a idéia é promover ainda é o design
imaginarem aquelas telas conseguem saber
qual é a situação que stalin escorpião
muito vai exatamente na fotografia de
baixo é um exemplo um quadro que nós
fizemos nossa última exposição em
setembro passado no uganda em que nós
convidamos os alunos
nós cremos na primeira turma do lado
esquerdo escrevemos uma série de
palavras relacionadas com a astronomia e
ciência e nós convidamos os alunos
durante os dois dias que estávamos em
cada escola
traduzir essas palavras do inglês para
as suas línguas nativas no brasil
existem mais de 50 tribos cada uma com a
sua língua de forma a continuar nosso
trabalho realizado à frente às pressões
nas escolas nós oferecemos material
didático e um caderno de atividades das
nossas atividades são centradas no
estudo é tão de professores os alunos
descobrem e experimentam aprendendo ao
mesmo tempo segue o mesmo caminho o
caminho
muito semelhante ao seguido pelos
investigadores do seu trabalho é ou
invés de apresentarmos resultados e as
conclusões de início
nós orientamos nós oferecemos factos e
pistas depois orientamos os estudantes
forma a chegarem às suas próprias
conclusões 1 acontece um processo de
investigação normal
as oficinas para professores são uma
componente muito importante nas nossas
visitas nas escolas pois dessa forma
poderão dar continuidade ao nosso
trabalho iam talvez vá terminar com esta
idéia de que o desenvolvimento
sustentável só é possível com base na
educação
isto é transversal para qualquer país
para qualquer cultura e por isso mesmo
são as pessoas quem tem realmente o
poder mudar o mundo não os políticos e
esta inversão podemos fazer está nas
nossas mãos para as mãos todos nós eu
vou deixar se não houver tempo com
espanha tem os fundos com o testemunho
de um aluno de uma das escolas que
visitamos um sentimento venda
infelizmente o vídeo não estava agendado
o sotaque é muito próprio espero
conseguir um parceiro praia disso leva
hannah information r&i nenhum plano das
noites na primeira corrida da próxima a
11 de agosto se disse kai ficou violenta
se a sair de dentro do ônibus em
movimento e leane física quando alguém
entra o escopo da respectiva autoria o
caminho ressaltou viu essa experiência
da vila
uma nova autoeuropa o fundo foi o gana e
limpa de chillán
adiantamos uma na fan daniel 40 enquanto
aceitam sorvete risco
obrigado